the work is a basic inquiry and it takes
it takes one into a meditative state
let's say if you're very stressed out
you just become still and you identify
what you were thinking and believing in
that situation let's say I'm at work and
and I have the thought you know this job
is stressing me out so I would simply
now that that thought is identified just
write it down on a piece of paper it's
stabilized from mind to reality it's
solid identified and anchored this job
my job is stressing me out
is it true but my job is stressing me
out and the first response might be yes
yes yes it's true my job stresses me out
no and he said this and she said that
and and this is more than I can handle
it okay no that's not inquiry that's a
discussion so now we slow it down look
at the paper this job is stressing me
out is it true that this job is
stressing me out now the answer to the
first two questions is one syllable it's
either yes or no this is inquiry any
defense or justification or story is not
inquiry inquiry is to get still and let
the answer show you it comes out as a
yes or no and so we just meditate on
that until that's why I say you know it
could take it could take a while
for some of us and then this my job is
stressing me out
can I absolutely know that it's my job
that's stressing me out okay really
still absolutely know that it's my job
that's stressing me out
yes
so to imagine that it's no you're just
guessing at the right answer so it has
to be authentic you cannot fool you you
can't fool you so some people say
ultimately every answer is no yes to me
is as valid as a note to someone else
this is personal work so that Samiti yes
so it's my job that's stressing me out
my job stresses me out how do I react
when I believe that thought I close my
eyes I see me taking it home with me
I see me frustrated at work I'm short
with my children my husband I want to
quit then I worry about money and
security hey my family down
I blame even innocent people at work I'm
focused on work most of the time I'm
paid for eight hours but I'm 24 waking
24/7 waking hours I'm at work in my head
and a lot of us can go further with that
you know it's like how do I react when I
believe the thought if we get really
still we can see that's when we go for
the chocolate cake or the cigarette we
said we'd never smoke again or the
alcohol my job is stressing me out
who would I be without that thought and
I start with right here right now I'm at
my desk who would I be without the
thought my job is stressing me out okay
so all of a sudden I'm present and
there's nothing here to stress me out
there's a desk there's my computer there
are people working that are not even
speaking to me my job is not stressing
me out so I look at the paper again my
job is stressing me out and I'm going to
turn it around my job is not stressing
me out so I might turn it around because
we have an object my thoughts about my
job or stressing me out my thinking is
stressing me out so is that that's true
or truer it's completely true
my thoughts about this job stress me out
so for me that completely shows me an
innocent world and in other words all
the people I'm working with my boss my
workload completely innocent
it's what I'm thinking and believing
about it that is the cause of my stress
so another turnaround is I sit in this
might be I am stressing my job out well
what does that mean to me that doesn't
mean much to people but this is my
Enquirer I'm sitting in this I'm this is
my meditation so so I'm stressing my job
out and then I begin to see how I when
I'm stressed out how I approach people
I'm short I can be argumentative when I
think my workload is just too much my
job is stressing me out
I'm rushed I'm not connected when other
people need help I'm not available not
compassionate not understanding why
isolate
thinking that I don't have time for this
person or that project I'm just focused
on this so I plan to be selfish with my
time I miss people connecting with them
and I've lost the ability to connect
with them I'm not connected to myself
I'm just thinking this you know my job
is stressing me out
so you you really can't guess if you're
doing authentic inquiry not rational
thinking but but just listening
witnessing watching being aware
everything shifts the way you see
everything shifts and that creative mind
is weightless